it is January 6 2023 and you're watching
the code report 2022 was a rough year
for web 3. and 2023 is already off to a
rocky start but like most of you out
there I became hell oppressed after
seeing my turbochad role model Logan
Paul be accused of scamming his audience
with his crypto Zoo nft project if
you're not already familiar coffeezilla
did a three-part series that presented a
ton of evidence about how the crypto Zoo
team made millions of dollars magically
disappear in all fairness nobody could
have possibly seen this coming to any
sane person digital eggs that hatch into
jpegs of pug or flies and pandarillas
seems like a perfectly Sound Investment
Shut Up And Take My Money and to his
credit Logan Paul never actually sold
his tokens or made any money from this
project although the Shady crypto Bros
he hired did it's a crazy story but in
this video I want to explain how it all
works from a software engineering
perspective by reverse engineering it so
that one day you too can mint your own
[ __ ] going and sell worthless jpegs to
differently abled kids on the blockchain
and you might be surprised at how easy
it actually is and there's all kinds of
cool stuff you can do with this tack
Beyond just nft scams so everything on
the blockchain is public by Design and
all the code for projects like cryptozoo
are compiled as smart contracts and that
means we can easily access its source
code from websites like BSC scan this
project is built on top of the ethereum
blockchain and uses the solidity
programming language which is an
object-oriented language like C plus
designed for writing smart contracts if
we inspect this code you'll notice the
first interface that it implements is
erc20 which is basically just your own
cryptocurrency built on top of ethereum
in this case it's the zoo token now the
other side of the equation is an ERC 721
contract which generates a non-fungible
token to represent the various images in
cryptozoo which you can think of as
digital Pokemon cards but more
interactive thanks to the code in this
contract like you can hatch an egg to
turn it into a base animal then with a
technique known as copulation you can
combine two animals into a freakish
hybrid now depending on how rare The
Offspring is it will yield the zooten
into your wallet on a daily basis and
the contract also forms an auction house
where these tokens can be traded now
this code was generated with a tool
called open Zeppelin which provides
industry standard templates for these
contracts in fact they have a wizard
where you can generate almost everything
you need without ever having to write a
single line of code another interesting
thing to point out is that the actual
images for the nfts are not stored on
the blockchain instead they live in a
decentralized file system called ipfs or
interplanetary file system which is
connected back to the nft Via its ID now
that you know how to write a smart
contract you might be wondering what you
should do with it the next step is to
compile it and deploy it to the
blockchain there are many tools that can
help you do that like hard hat and
truffle for JavaScript development or
there's the remix IDE that can take care
of it entirely from the browser now the
final step is the front end we'll need a
website where our victim valued
community members can purchase these
nfts and breed them into these horrible
monstrosities like most web3 apps it's
built with react.js but the secret sauce
is a library called ethersjs which allow
allows you to connect to a deployed
smart contract and connect to a user's
wallet with browser plugins like
metamask which itself provides this
ethereum object on the window
facilitating secure transactions in your
app or dap or d-app if you prefer and
that's how cryptozoo Works in a nutshell
when it comes to the scam it really has
nothing to do with the underlying
technology the problem is that I trusted
Logan Paul to take my hard-earned money
to the Moon without any kind of
insurance or protection and now I have
to have a very difficult conversation
with my wife about why our kids can't go
to college this has been the code report
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one